[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors vous avez vu comme c'était me suis
construite elle et elle est s'est tous
serré tout petit bébé indique t il ya un
vrai film attention parce que c'est pas
du tout dans le nez le garçon je sais
les torontoises a en fait ils jouent
dans ma pièce josé philippe vasseur et
on rentrait du festival d'avignon
ensemble et on a chanté ça a été repris
par évidemment tous les médias bien sûr
parce que chanter mais c'est pas en tout
cas je vous dire je trouve que c'est un
très beau moment de vie exactement
vous avez bien fait de le passer je
ressemble vraiment vraiment vraiment
pour bourgoin comment ça va c'est vrai
que vous avez qu'aujourd'hui armes il ya
beaucoup de choses on va on va parler
notamment des beats de jean michel et il
va voir le switch bon rap et le switch
et l'autre lors autour du switch sont
les bides de gens ici aiment bien de
libido au cinéma et de grands duos
comiques comme gérard depardieu pierre
richard mais dans tpm puis on a un autre
duo comique cyril hanouna et benjamin
castaldi n'a jamais été clairement le
souffre douleur de l'ani marge la dose
tu sais que vous allez voir vous
connaissez le film l'emmerdeur ça dort
tous les nuits mais je mets à ja je
perds le concert vous allez voir ça me
regarde tout le temps vous allez voir
vous allez voir vous nous tapez pardon
non je vous me tarde que vous vous me
taper vous me taper et je me défonce non
non vous me demandez de vous attaquer
oui à chaque fois je vais attendre comme
inconsciente et laqué attaque aller
faire un petit tour de la dalle et
partir vous allez avoir trois minutes
pour nous faire un exposé sur le 1er mai
et vous revenez dans trois minutes
allez-y d'un portable il est 20 heures
17 à 20 heures d'un annonçant portable
sans partage allez-y merci
[Applaudissements]
elle m'a mis à part peut-être les
baskets aller 2 2 parce que je vous dis
demain il y aura neuf places pour la
tunisie vous serez 15 et je vous le dis
je ne tricherai pas non mais je vous
jure que c'est vrai ceux qui doivent
partir partiront ceux qui ne peuvent pas
partir ne partiront pas voilà et je vous
dit il n'y aura pas deux y'aura pas de
duras voilà c'est on part en part on
part en part par vous venez tous avec
votre valise qu'elle se sera un départ
immédiat
voilà une et demain bien sûr durant la
suite de la grande race sera aussi en
prime avec une caméra cachée avec jean
michel maire je vous jure on en a pleuré
vraiment pleuré
jean michel a été exceptionnel vous
verrai ça demain merci en tout cas bravo
auto merci beaucoup belle frimousse pro
ça fait plaisir merci
alors tous les quinze jours je fais un
point pascal praud celui qui présente la
meilleure action actuelle leur des pros
dernière fois on est bon on l'avait
laissée impôt aura sera comme on dit
chez nous témoigne balances ton post
touche pas à mon poste et de la mer non
mais ça ça compte fois c'est au dessus
et bella yom c'est que de la télé ça
c'est encore au dessus le télescope est
naïve et une âme bien oui c'est vrai je
sais elle a beaucoup changé mais on a
l'habitude de la voir la loi alors on
avait laissé pascal praud menaçant ses
chroniqueurs de quitter le plateau
tellement c'était le bordel
alors là il tente de trouver des
stratagèmes pour anesthésier sa bande je
lui remets laurie duca qui pensaient
pouvoir calmer ses chroniqueurs juste
avec un sifflet
ça il faut y faire attention parce que
merci jacques sd il faut parce que si on
est recyclé siècle ont aussi fait
honneur et de son sifflet les
chroniqueurs de pascal praud n'ont
absolument rien à faire regarder ce qui
se passe en retour publicité mes
chroniqueurs s'en [ __ ] complètement
d'avoir repris l'antenne n'ai jamais vu
ça j'ai pas vu d'une chez causeur
leggera j'ai des années j'ai été député
parrain six mandats tellement mis une
fois on a une et t on sépare menaces à
50 fois gérable et un bon gars et était
complètement choqué lui non plus herman
bt il y en a eu assez ridicule mais je
savais dans sa capitale thaïlandaise
attention bon
bien content en tout cas j'adore
pourtant tout est formidable mais pascal
praud alors il ya une émission où chaque
jour il ya une ambiance semblable à une
soirée chez valérie benaïm c'est des
chiffres et des lettres
ah ouais l'info c'est la folie à la
folie et comme laurent romejko sont
venus pendant son émission de laisser
passer son temps à se moquer de ce port
où bertrand renard je remets laurent
romejko le leur et du gars qui craque
complètement en comparant bertrand
renard un chien c'est incroyable vous
allez voir
ouais d'accord merci carhaix karaez
c'est lui un peu la tête là bertrand là
pour le faut le féliciter et bien
bertrand cherche le comte chercheurs
comptent bertrand qui prend pas si
maintenant il fera pour son film non
mais je rêve
6 et 2 bertrand 484 crois qu'ils sont
prêts pour aller sur une autre émission
culturelle maintenant il est vraiment
cherche le comte bertrand sets à rien et
le bois les habitants pinera
j'aime derniers mois à lavau castaldi et
allez ça va on est bien réveillé comme
ça mais tu as des petits yeux et on est
aujourd'hui j'ai déjà trop de pin à
rester corrects belle j'aime bien des
yeux comme ça c'est très beau ouais
ouais mais c'est un mois on voit vos
yeux plus on voit votre gueule il a une
belle gueule mais je vois comment ils
nous voient en fait seul truc qui ne
voient pas ils voient tous les jours
tout petit toujours pas seulement un
épisode de joséphine ange gardien
non messieurs alors y'a quelqu'un que
j'admire particulièrement ici voilà
particulièrement parce que c'est un
modèle pour la jeunesse française de par
son élégance et sa classe légendaire
c'est bien sûr jean michel maire voilà
c'est vraiment le plus chez lui la
classe c'est son courage
pourquoi parce que dans l'émission il
tente des vannes que personne n'oserait
faire et ce qui est encore plus
manifeste que j'adore c'est que malgré
des échecs tu continues et ça c'est
magnifique c'est un kamikaze de la barca
je remets à jean michel lory lucas
qu'elle a peut-être la plus marrante
quand il se rend compte qu'il prend un
bide phénoménal ont fait andré genia ben
qu'est ce qu'un par le grand rabbin
séminaire à main est ce que c'est qu'une
limace séance cargo qui a divorcé
c'est vrai que c'était autant qu'avant
qu'ils étaient dans un tombeau mais avec
ils l'ont laissée en érection hillion
bordel zynga se trouvent parfois elle
revient vous demandez la baule en 2h
2h30 on peut faire à faire s'il fait on
l'aimé taka mange dort sets s'il vous
plaît les gens sont l'on peut pas dire
que ce soit un truc si vous mettez en
journée et pas quand je prends mes
médicaments j'arrive à dormir à la belle
étoile avait les bottes franchement elle
avait les bons mais ils seront avec des
bottes aujourd'hui elle avait des rucks
et je veux dire qui ne tente rien n'a
rien ban sur le toit de chaume du cuir
sort commun qu'est ce que vous dites
dans le nombril john qui finit par
passer par personne vous fait rien mais
jean michel mr oui tu sais pas quoi dire
il fait des longues il est long on les a
marqués ou quoi quand il a pas vous
aimez le fromage me
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est aimer la salade
non il est marrant c'est pas sa faute
parfois ça marche bien sûr mais c'est
qu'il pleut rôle ici vous autour de la
table en chroniqueur non dans le public
et lille
mais c'est vrai qu'elle est très drôle
c'est vrai écoute ça voilà parce qu'en
fait il comprend les vannes de khalid
deux jours après être entrés chez alors
pour finir je préparais donc un nouveau
switch
j'ai pris des voix de valérie benaïm
matthieu delormeau gilles verdez et vous
seriez la nonna j'ai déposé sur d'autres
personnalités qu'on ne verrait pas dire
de telles phrases s'invite encore plus
loin qu'à sonas camplong fait que moi à
cette fois on est en mai où vous allez
vous avez dit je travaille je travaille
vous rendez compte gérer ça cogite
tellement vous en perdez vos cheveux
exactement
voilà donc un nouvel épisode du switch
s'est déjà blessé aux côtes il est ce
que vous êtes déjà pas mal au cul cul ça
dépend des cas mais on pourrait dire en
un sens que oui c'est qu'elle est lille
qui est à côté de mykonos foule à moi
dans l'os
est ce que le zizi c'est du gras alors
non ça va être un nouveau départ une
nouvelle inspiration c'est à vous de
vous adresser au président de la
république tchèque avant le coeur très
très tendre et la tob très très dur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]